This is what you've been waiting for.
Hello world,
it's the Raj and welcome to my new
course on AI applied to business.
The most valuable course I've ever made.
We're going to build a simple AI app for
doctors that lets them upload a picture
of an eye and tells them whether or
not that I has diabetic retinopathy.
If you're looking to build a profitable
AI startup or implement AI at your
company in some way,
this is the course for you.
All my videos will be free and
available, right? You're on Youtube,
so make sure to subscribe to stay
up to date with my latest content.
Advances in medicine over the past
few decades have improved health care
immensely,
allowing doctors to more efficiently
diagnose and treat diseases,
but doctors are still humans,
which means they understandably still
make mistakes on the epic. A APP,
TV show house doctor houses
genius bar exceeds his colleagues,
which implies that if all
doctors were as smart as him,
diagnostic mysteries and unnecessary
deaths in hospitals would drastically
decrease.
But the reality is that the biggest
difference between doctors is not their
level of intelligence.
It's how they approach patient problems
and the type of health system that
supports them.
This combination is what causes such
wide variations in clinical outcomes and
it's the reason why machine learning is
the best solution out there to improve
doctors capabilities. If
you can't beat them, join a,
there's so much potential here.
For example,
studies show that over half of all women
in the US who get regular mammograms
will receive at least one false positive,
which is a test that wrongly indicates
the possibility of cancer in a 10 year
period.
Radiologists regularly disagree on their
respective interpretations of medical
images.
Ai Can do what no radiologists can.
It can learn from hundreds of thousands
of medical images and is estimated to be
up to 10% more accurate than
the average radiologist.
That accuracy gap will only increase as
computing power gets cheaper and can be
applied to any of the countless
subfields of medicine,
not just radiology,
like what the startup this dot.
Ai is doing for brain scans.
Doctors also have to interpret
patient medical records,
which can be a very complex task and LP,
a branch of AI that helps
computers understand and
interpret human language can
review thousands of medical records and
output the optimal steps for evaluating
and managing patients with many illnesses.
Some doctors really are gifted
at what they do like Doctor Oz.
Just kidding.
And Ai can learn from the best
by watching them do their work.
If all doctors matched the performance
of the top 20% patient deaths from a
variety of diseases would decrease by
the hundreds of thousands per year.
And wild doctors have natural biases.
Ai is more likely to produce objective
diagnoses for patients without
preconceived socioeconomic notions,
which can produce disparities in care.
Ml will become an essential tool for
doctors like the stethoscope has been and
as more of the profession is automated,
human empathy and compassion for patients
will become paramount to their success
in the field. Also good
looks. Let's just be real.
So how do we pick a problem to solve?
The AI in health care market is expected
to grow at an incredible 48% compound
annual growth rate in the next five
years according to research and markets.
The tech giants like Google and
Microsoft have massive amounts of data,
talent and computing power.
They have a huge advantage when it
comes to building horizontal products.
These are products that can
be applied to many use cases,
but as a startup you can
build a vertical product,
one that tackles a single problem very
well since they don't have the time to do
that.
One way to do this is to find relevant
problems in online communities where
doctors congregate. These can
be forums, slack channels,
sub reddits,
Grey's anatomy,
chat rooms about McDreamy and see
what kind of problems they're having.
Another way would be to call
up or schedule a visit to
a local practice to hear
firsthand about the type of problems
they're having. Listening before,
acting is an important first step when
finding the right problem to solve.
Eventually we'll come across a problem
that is dealt with by multiple doctors.
Let's say for the case of this demo
it's diagnosing diabetic retinopathy
correctly. We can build a classifier
to help solve this problem,
but first we've got to
collect some quality data.
The foundation of all machine learning
is having lots of quality data.
That's how it learns.
Very few companies actually
generate and own medical grade data.
Since collecting this data from
patients is quite difficult,
so we're going to have
to get a little creative.
We can search the web by searching
public imaging data sets for diabetic
retinopathy.
We'll come across a few.
Some will require us to apply and register
before getting access so we can go
ahead and do that and hope for the best.
Alternatively,
if you're a student at a university,
you can go find the nearest
imaging research center and
ask the professor there.
They're always willing
to help with projects.
Pub Med is also a great place to
find biomedical research papers.
We can search for papers by the type of
scan data we're looking for and once we
find a good one, we can just
email those researchers directly,
explain our project and how it can
be mutual beneficial to both of us.
If we frame it more like
we're trying to help them,
then asking them for something,
they'll be more likely to help us.
If we can get our hands
on a quality dataset,
ideally with labels because labeled
datasets are always easier to learn from,
then we know that we have a
shot at solving this problem,
but before we actually invest our time
and energy into building an AI model,
we need to make sure that
we're able to get customers.
The easiest way to do this is
to create a simple landing page.
We can find a template pretty
easily online that asks
for a simple email signup.
We'd explain our product in detail and
the landing page and once we have it we
can send it to potential clients.
In our case,
that would be doctors
and medical companies.
We can find a directory of them online
and email them one by one posted in
Facebook groups and see
if we get any signups.
If we're able to get a
sufficient amount of signups,
then we know that there is indeed interest
in our product and we can go ahead
and start building.
There's an entire ecosystem of libraries
and services that help us build models.
Archive sanity is a great tool to help
us search for how the latest AI models
have been applied to medical
diagnoses and research labs.
Once we find a cool paper, we can use it
as a guide to help build our own model.
It's important to remember that there
are so many tweaks and modifications we
could potentially make to
our model to improve it,
but the best thing to do is to first
build a prototype that works as fast as
possible and then iterate from there.
Convolutional neural networks are a type
of model that have proven to outperform
all others.
When it comes to image classification,
which is our use case.
The fastest and easiest way to build a
convolutional neural network is by using
the care os machine learning library.
It lets us build neural networks
easily with its high level API.
Each line of code corresponds to a
different layer in our neural network.
We can search get hub for
an image classification
care model and use that as a
base model. Notice how the perimeters
all seem like magic numbers.
How are we supposed to know
which numbers are optimal?
This is the art of deep learning.
Figuring out the right parameters for
a certain type of model is the kind of
thing that research papers
focus on in this field.
Sometimes a simple tweak gives
rise to a breakthrough in accuracy.
We can use similar parameters to the
paper we chose to start and train this
model on our dataset. I have a Mac book
pro. Love you, apple. Let's Collab. Kay,
thanks, bye. And not a deep learning rig.
So I found that the best bet for me
is to upload my model to Floyd hub,
which is a platform as a service that
helps train deep learning models in the
cloud. We can do this in the command
line with just a few commands.
What it's doing is learning the
mapping between the input data,
which are the medical
images and the output data,
which are the diagnoses of the images.
Once it's learned this
pattern given a new image,
it can accurately predict what the
diagnosis is. Once it's done training,
we can use Floyd hub to create a basic
API call where we merely send it an image
and it will return the
prediction of that image.
With any web framework of our choice,
we can build a single web page that
asks the user to upload an image.
It will call the API and returned the
prediction for the user to see just like
that. From here, we can make programmatic
improvements, add a better design,
and finally start collecting some
sales. Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I've got three things for you
to remember from this video.
Ai Can help doctors better approach
patient problems and improve the health
system that supports them.
Improving diagnoses,
interpreting patient medical
history and drug discovery,
or just a few of the potential
practices that AI can improve on.
And we can build a simple model using
the Karrass deep learning library.
Then train and deploy it using Floyd hub.
Want to be friends?
Hit the subscribe button and I'm all
yours for now. I've got to see my robot.
I mean doctor,
so thanks for watching.